ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage
dave reuben
holy [ __ ] are you real people
are you guys real people look at this
a room full of real people
in 2020 this is absolutely incredible
you guys
are doing the greatest protest in
american history
right this second
[Applause]
[Music]
i did not think when i signed on to do
sas
this year that my first speech of 2020
was also going to be my last speech of
2020.
but they shut us down all year right i
have not spoke in front of people all
year this is
this is my favorite thing to do i mean
far more than doing a youtube show and
interviewing people and babbling to the
camera
actually seeing real live human beings
and
i come from a place a different place
than florida okay i come from a place
some of you may have heard of called
[Music]
california
recall gavin there you go
i come from a place that is completely
locked down
i have not seen people i went out i got
here in florida yesterday freedom love
in florida
yeah you know what i did you're not
gonna believe this
i went to a place called a restaurant
okay i sat down
a woman who i did not know approached
the table
she took my order and 15 minutes later
food arrived can you believe that guys
that
that is what can happen in the great
state of florida that
yeah it can't happen it can't happen in
california so i was thinking guys
you've been here for a couple days
you've heard a ton of great speakers
youtubers podcasters politicians all
that stuff
i was thinking well what can i say
that's different what can i say that's
different at this point
and i try to never give the the same
speech twice you guys know
i was on tour with jordan peterson for
about a year and a half
[Music]
love jordan and he's coming back guys
he's coming back
[Music]
i promise you he's going to be back and
better than ever and and it's coming
and it can't be too soon but one of the
things when i toured with jordan he
never gave the same speech twice and i
really try to do that so i was trying to
think well what can i say to these guys
that's different than every other
speaker has said
and here's the truth guys here's the
real truth for you guys that are in high
school that are in college
you right now you're about to hit the
prime of your
life right you are about to hit the
prime of your life okay
and what that means is that you are
growing up in the most
unique time possibly possibly since the
inception of this country
everything everything is up for grabs
right now
right i mean imagine this if you would
have said to anyone
anyone you know back in february hey do
you realize
uh nine months from now you're going to
be locked in your house you're not going
to be going to work you're not going to
be going to school
you're going to be taking classes on
zoom you're not going to go to
restaurants
they're going to you know put no fans in
the nba
and the football games and everything
else you would have told them that they
were bananas
and that's real that's real right now so
when i tell you guys
that you are protesting in the most
beautiful freaking way possible right
now you really are
[Applause]
and you have an opportunity because i'm
telling you guys the the generations
before you that have done a ton of good
right we've
we've fought wars against real nazis not
imaginary nazis right we've done
we've expanded freedoms right we've
expanded freedoms for women and for
black people and for gay people and all
of these things that america has done
and it's this place this idea as my
friend dennis prager calls it america is
this
this idea that everyone can come from
every walk of earth
from whatever religion whatever region
whatever nationality whatever skin color
we can all come to this magical place
and make it better and yet right now you
guys 18
20 22 years old it's on you to fix this
thing
because something ain't right and we all
know something ain't right right
something is not right here and it's up
to you guys and that's
pretty freaking powerful so i know a lot
of you kind of feel like
well who's gonna who's gonna come and
fix this right and donald trump has done
a hell of a lot
donald trump has done a hell of a lot
[Applause]
man if dave rubin of 2018 would ever
heard dave rubin at 2020 saying that
but that's the truth you know i'll tell
you this i'll tell you this one year ago
today
one year ago today at sas donald trump
spoke and then
i met trump jr backstage he said hey you
want to join me at
mar-a-lago tonight for dinner so my
husband
i'm gay big damn whoop i know you guys
don't care
all right zippity-doodah very exciting
well that tells you that tells you all
you need to know conservatives
conservatives want people to be free
right conservatives
[Applause]
so one year ago tonight my husband and i
went to
uh dinner at mar-a-lago with trump jr
and kimberly guilfoy we're sitting there
we're in there
and for those of you that haven't been
to mar-a-lago it kind of looks like
trump it's very shiny
and it looks very kind of hair spray and
the whole thing
and we're sitting like 10 feet away from
trump and you remember a year ago that
was the middle of
the impeachment the sham the absolute
sham impeachment that they put
this guy through and if you're watching
cnn you're watching msnbc as that's
going on
they're telling him trump's freaking out
the walls are closing in they're coming
to get him
we're sitting there the guy's laughing
up the storm he's sitting next to rudy
giuliani who has the biggest head
you've ever seen this guy's head is like
got its own orbit but he's sitting there
and he's got no tie on and he's relaxed
and his hair is a little floppier than
usual
and junior says to me at the end of the
meal he says hey you guys want to meet
my dad
i was like all right i guess i'll meet
the president why not well
meet the president right we go up to to
the president
and he's sitting down and junior says to
him hey dad
uh this is dave rubin he's a podcaster
he's got a great show
uh and trump looks up at me and he goes
he goes i kind of recognize you kind of
recognize you
i said oh well i'm on i'm on tucker a
lot maybe it's that he goes oh yeah that
must be it and then he looks at
my husband he goes well who are you and
he goes well i'm his husband
he goes husband he slaps his hands on
the table
he stands up he goes that is great you
know what that is great and i want you
guys to know i don't give a [ __ ]
[Applause]
and the reason i mention that to you
guys is because i know that many
people in this room have some different
religious differences some philosophical
differences some existential differences
but what i know is that right now guys
it's
all of us versus the woksters that's
what it is
that's what it is
they are coming for every single one of
you and if you think you're protected
because you're black or you're gay
or you're trans or you've got a limp or
a lazy eye or you're a half a lesbian
it will not protect you it will half a
lesbian
if you're a small lesbian um
it will not protect you guys it really
won't because this thing
this thing that we're fighting it's
spreading like a virus right now
and it is on you guys to fix it the
cavalry ain't coming
there are a couple people that are
fighting it and a lot of them were on
this stage over the last couple days and
will continue to be here
but it is on you guys it is on you guys
in your life
to stand up for what you believe in that
is the only way we fix this thing the
adults
have dropped the ball it's just how it
is there's a lot of reasons for that
that
are for a much longer speech the adults
have dropped the ball and you guys have
a chance
and the reason i'm actually enthused the
reason i can end this year with a smile
on my face
while this whole thing has been such a
disaster
is because i see you guys i see it and i
know something good can happen
and we know now that that young people
are swinging way
conservative but not conservative the
way they want to frame conservatism oh
these are these
close-minded bigots and the rest of it
conservative meaning you want to
conserve
freedom and man i will stand there with
you every step of the way
[Applause]
but i know i could babylon for a long
time and i always like end in the year
by getting a little bit from you guys so
there are two microphones out here let's
do a little quick q a give me something
good guys give me something good
to end on where where are the mics where
am i sorry people are running already we
got a mic
we'll do it real quick oh we got 800
people i'm gonna
give one word answers we'll do it real
fast everybody
where is it what's that how is it
working for the young turks you know i'm
trying not to curse too much these days
so i'm gonna have to pass on that
question
um yeah yeah you could figure it all
right here we go here we go
i'll do them quick hi so my name is didi
my question to you is about middle
ground
obviously as students we want to be able
to be the reasonable ones and have
conversations with
those we disagree with or those who
disagree with us
but we also don't want to give up too
much middle ground because they
don't seem to do the same for us so my
question to you is
what is the key thing to keep in mind
when trying to talk to someone you
disagree with
in terms of giving up middle ground that
way you seem reasonable
but not overstepping all right i'm going
to try to do them as quickly as possible
so i can get to as many of you as
possible
the best way is all you got to do is be
a little bit better than them and guys
that ain't that tough because they're
pretty terrible
okay that really that really is the
truth
that really is the truth what are they
going to do you've all been in these
arguments you're a racist you're a big
you're a homophobe all of these things
be a little bit better be a little more
gracious than they will be
and you can actually win these people
over because at the end of the day
nobody wants to be miserable but what is
at the end
of leftism they think they're bringing
you to some utopia and they're just
bringing you to endless misery
and if you can show them if you could
show them that boy you know if you
believe in personal responsibility
you believe in freedom you believe in
the ability for people to compete for
things to make a better society and all
of those things
you know what will happen one day
they're going to wake up and they're
going to go oh
they were right so just be a little bit
better that's all you got to do
hi dave mine's pretty similar to what he
said but
you just had kind of an amazing
conversion so to speak
and how can i be a good example to my
friends what can i do to help them
to also turn yeah well it's a little bit
of the first answer that you got to be a
little bit better
but i think the other thing that you can
do is welcome the conversation you know
i think partly what's happening also is
the more that you know we watch
mainstream media collapse and cnn is a
joke
and msnbc is a joke in the new york
times i wouldn't
i don't have a parrot but if i did i
wouldn't even use it to line his
cage like the more that these things
collapse the more that we're all going
to go into our ideological echo chambers
right the more that you guys are going
to go all right well i'll watch
i'll watch shapiro and i'll watch reuben
and whatever it is on this side and i'm
not even going to pay attention to their
side
pay it pay a little attention to what
they're doing pay a little attention to
what they're doing
and know that some of this is just a
little bit of a of a psychological
makeup
sometimes they're maybe a little more
sensitive than you might be sometimes
they're maybe they're occasionally
seeing something that you aren't
but but you can figure out a way and
remind them that you're a real person
because i know what happens you tell
them oh i'm a conservative i'm a
libertarian
i'm just anything but woke and they'll
say the worst things about you and it's
like well what do you mean we've been
friends since i was five years old
you're telling me i'm the worst
of all things and there are ways to just
be a human just be a little bit better
that really is the answer
hi my name is roman i'm from san
francisco california
um prayers are accepted one thing
a refugee everybody a refugee from san
francisco
um so one thing that i'm noticing is
that people are leaving my state in mass
numbers specifically liberals and they
are going to red states
but they are not understanding that the
left-leaning policies that they voted
for
were responsible for ruining their home
state and they're bringing those to
other states
i've tried talking to many people about
this issue but they are reluctant to
facing
what's been going on and how they
actually contributed to it back home in
california
and how they're bringing it elsewhere
what can i and other californians do
yeah great question and as a guy that
lives in la i hear you man i hear you
listen first off if you live in a red
state you should build a wall i want to
be very clear about that
well now now i know which portion of
this speech media matters is going to
clip at the end
dave rubin calls for a wall around
florida okay
um no what you do have to be aware of
though
is that it's great that all of these
lefties are waking up and they're going
holy cow i want to live in a free state
right i want to be able to live in a
place with low taxes and low regulation
so i can
build businesses and they're all moving
to texas they're all moving to florida
and all these things that's fantastic
but what you don't want is them bringing
all of the bad ideas
and one of the things that's so tricky
about leftism is a lot of times i see
this all the time in la
people can't make the connection between
voting for these big government high-tax
people and the fact that everything
around them is crumbling
so the best that you can do is try to
educate them get them get them to
watch some of these videos watch some
larry elder videos watch some thomas
soul videos that's really what you got
to do get them to thomas soul
have them learn a little something about
economics supply and demand and
understand that the government
is not some magical thing that made us
free we're born free and the
government's supposed to stay out of our
freaking way
that's it that's it and fight for that
and then you got a chance
all right hey i'm spencer from boise
idaho
and and the question i have is how do
you get
liberals and conservatives to work
together and help can
liberals understand that we need to work
together and combat the left
yeah you know what's so interesting so
i've taken what four or five questions
already
and several of them are about the same
things you guys want to work with the
other side
you guys actually want to work with the
other side that kind of means you guys
are good
right
you think at lefty conferences do they
have conferences
uh would be terrible but if they did
you're racist no you're racist you're a
racist um
but do you think they're going how do we
reach out how do we reach out to the
conservatives how do we
how do we no of course they're not doing
it because what they've done is they've
made politics a religion
and religion is religion politics is not
religion
so so again it's it's the same answer as
before you gotta
keep showing them that just because you
don't want the government to do
everything for you and for them doesn't
mean you're a bad person that actually
it means you're a good person it means
you're an evolved person
it means you're somebody who believes in
yourself and you want to give yourself a
chance to succeed
because the government's not coming to
save you and
and the speakers at a conference like
this who are all doing good work in
their own way
we can't save you you have to save
yourself
you guys will build the better
businesses of the future you'll build
the new twitters and the new youtubes
and and the new googles and all those
things but you guys got to do it it's as
simple as that and if you do that
if you do that then that would be a
pretty good day
hey how you doing uh i'm jorge i run
center millennials
and as you know uh accentures is
somebody who wants to
play left and play right now i run with
a little bit of the chris rock mentality
of
hey i'm a little bit liberal on this
side i'm a little bit conservative on
this side
but with the growing division of a lot
of the conservatives i see today
like how can i integrate my centrism to
get people to be more
like not divided so much like for the
left the right
and even within the right yeah it's a
good question you know i'm the new guy
on the right so
you know when i see these divisions that
i hear some of you guys talking about
okay so we've got
the more traditional conservatives let's
say we've got the more libertarian side
of it
and whatever else you want to whittle it
down to to me that's great because i
know you guys are all in this room right
now that that is fantastic
right there are believers in this room
there are non-believers in this room
you've got you've got people that come
from a purely libertarian side of things
there are people that want
a little more government involvement all
of those things those are little side
issues just designed to make you hate
each other you want to live free you
want to live free you want to live by
the constitution
hey we're in the best country to do it
right as simple as that
don't worry about the little problems we
got
we got a much bigger problem and that is
a woke freaking monster that is trying
to eat us
so either team up with some people that
maybe want a slightly higher
marginal tax rate than you do or or
you're gonna be eaten by the monster
and it's very obvious to me which one of
those is the right choice all right
um hi my name is topher um
i have two questions first off can i
replace will wit
and will i replace will wit will i reply
i don't know
good hair that guy i'll give him that
much um
second off um i hear you more described
as a
um liberal not a leftist um
could you describe the difference
between those sometimes
i can do it i wrote a book about it so
look a
leftist if well let's do a liberal first
if you're a liberal i actually think
that most of you here
are liberal in the true sense of the
word liberal meaning you're classical
liberals which is that you believe
in individual rights individual rights
that's what you want right
you want individual rights i know that
you guys don't care what color
somebody's skin is i know you don't care
what gender
they are i know you don't even care
about what gender they identify as you
want people
that are abiding by the laws of some of
the nation
to be treated equally that's the core
tenet of classical liberalism
and then you want laissez-faire
economics you want the market to work
and you want logic and reason these are
these are liberal principles that have
been hijacked by the left so what's the
difference between the left and liberals
well leftism is about government power
leftism is about saying okay
we somehow us the imperfect humans can
create this perfect system and if only
everyone could behave in our perfect
system
we would be in shangri-la we'd be in
utopia and you know who
thought like that thanos you guys
remember thanos
what did thanos what did thanos want to
do in the marvel world right in the
avengers movie thanos saw
a universe with with finite resources
and what did he say he said i'll do the
thing that nobody will do
i will wipe out half of the life in the
universe
in the name of creating peace and that
actually is how the left behaves which
is why
communism and socialism these things
that come with a smile on your on their
face right it's free healthcare and free
education and all of these free things
because we love you
we're not trying to indoctrinate you we
just love you well you know what you got
to do you got to kill a lot of people on
the way
and that's why communism and socialism
have a history of murder
and all of the worst ideas so that that
in a nutshell is the difference between
left and liberal
and i think we got one more we got one
more yeah this is the last question
and then i'm going into hiding for the
rest of the year by the way guys i'm not
going back to california i'm literally
hiding somewhere in florida and if you
can find me i'll give you a cookie
all right hi dave i'm ben i'm from
california
um i know but uh i just wanted to ask
you you know i've seen
a lot of people grassroots in california
that have been stepping up and
supporting the president and i just
wanted to ask you like
as somebody who's gone from the more the
left
to now you you support the right and you
still have your liberal um
like your your classical liberalism
right which is awesome uh but how do we
like encourage more people to come out
and support
and um and kind of foster this um
this movement that we've seen in
california because i don't know you've
seen the rallies and just the
the car parades and stuff and yeah
california has to be red right like it
looks like california's red just
it's crazy i don't know if any of you
saw the videos i i went to a trump rally
by accident i was driving home and i
stopped at the beverly hills trump rally
i didn't even know it was happening
and i walked out there and it was the
most joyous
love fest of diverse
truly diverse
black people hispanic people white
people gay people asian and nobody
cares nobody cares right nobody cares
and that's what they're trying to trick
you
you see what they're doing they are
trying to use the strength of america
in that we all come here you look around
this room everyone in this room
you come from people who had it much
worse than you every single one of you
right every single one of you think
about your grandparents for a second
i guarantee you there's nobody in this
room who has it worse than their
grandparents everybody basically has it
better
everyone has it better that's because of
america guys that is the truth
and that now is what you are trying to
conserve
as conservatives that's what you should
be trying to conserve that this
experiment
is not bad that the left is trying to
trick you that the founding of america
was not 1776 and the incredible
documents the declaration of
independence and the constitution
that have freed all of us they're trying
to trick you into thinking that the
founding of
america was the 1619 project and that
slavery was the fundamental issue
that ran everything that caused all of
this and that all of our founders
were these evil racists and you know
what they were guys they were people of
their time
they were people of their time just like
you guys are people of your time yeah
and here's the beauty to wrap it all up
guys here's the beauty
while you guys can serve the good things
while you guys can serve liberty and you
can serve freedom
and you can serve all of the ideas that
allow you to live the life that you want
i don't care what you do in your life i
don't you can't have my stuff
that's it okay you can do what you want
and that
that's that's the american spirit that's
the american dream you got a chance you
got a chance
but what they will do is destroy
themselves in the process because the
progressives of today
the people who are silencing you and
calling you all of these things
the progressives of today will be hated
by the progressives of tomorrow
okay and you know why because they're
always looking for progress but progress
isn't a destination right that's just
like going
and there's a cliff coming and you know
it's coming but you're going to go over
either way
so let's not forget barack obama ran for
president
the first time in 2008 he was against
gay marriage
well what do you think the progressives
of 2040 are going to think of this guy
they're going to go well wait a minute
that guy was against gay marriage he was
a homophobe
and they will want to burn down his
library and by their own rules they'll
be allowed to do it
so you know what to package this all
together guys
just know what you believe and don't be
afraid to say it
and if you do that if you do that you
will change the world in extraordinary
ways
you have a chance in a way that that
people literally 20 years ago could have
never imagined
you had a phone and you might have a
thought that you can get out on twitter
or a five second
video that you put up on tick tock or
whatever it is and you can change the
world in an instant
you can do that and the people before
you couldn't so do that
fight for this freaking country while we
still got it because it's feeling
it's feeling tenuous guys fight for it
and i will stand with you guys as a
conservative all along the way
thank you very much and god bless
america
all right everybody thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell